all right it's three o'clock everybody I
will try to stay on time here my name is
Chris Fonz Beck I work in baseball
operations and player development for
the New York Yankees though I live in
Nashville we are hiring by the way
particularly if you're a data engineer
we love to hear from you I'm going to
talk today obviously about Gaussian
processes first some boring technical
stuff if you haven't seen the repository
already here it is don't worry if you
haven't you don't have to do everything
hands-on but you can if you want it's
github.com slash my last name /gp
underscore regression there are
instructions on installing a content
environment etc and so on on the rimi
page if you did install it already you
might want to look at it again
particularly if you're on Mac OS
catallena I have run into problems with
the new version of Mac OS with some of
the GP stuff but if all else fails I've
got the happy little launch binder
button here so you can spin up a machine
remotely wherever binder exists and run
it that way
or you can just sit back and relax and
enjoy like a lecture sort of thing so
it's up to you but these these I won't
move this repository it will always be
here for you so how many here have used
Gaussian processes before in their own
work okay good
how many people have used Bayesian
methods in their own work before how
many people have used PI mc3 before okay
this is perfect all right let's get
going then I my original plan was to do
a whole bunch of notebooks and I changed
course kind of at the last minute and I
sort of have a hybrid approach here so
I'm gonna because a lot of this stuff is
expository
is that the right word didactic so and I
think slides are better for that sort of
thing and then we'll switch over to
particular notebooks when we need them
and the idea here is to give you a
little bit of background and then give
you some hands-on building GPS on your
own just to give you kind of practice
and I probably have more examples than
we'll go through and that gives us a
little flexibility in case we run you
know short or long on time so please
interrupt me and ask questions
GPS aren't the easiest topic in the
world to understand the first time
around even for very smart people so it
took me five or six times before I
really got it
so if you even if you leave today not
knowing quite what they're all about
don't worry it it's not you and it may
not even be me it's just a hard topic
okay what we want to do here is to give
you some methodological practice and
some implementation practice this isn't
a theory course even though you will see
math and I will explain all the math but
do ask questions if anything is not
understandable okay so the reason we're
talking about Gaussian processes is that
they're very useful like Bayesian
methods in general they're very flexible
method for doing nonlinear regression
and classification though we won't talk
much about classification here in a
whole bunch of settings and it's a in a
class of it is a class of Bayesian
nonparametric models and and like I said
there's a whole it's a large topic we're
not going to cover it all in an hour and
a half this is just going to be a sort
of a quick introduction to them so again
the motivation is kind of in their
utility right it's the fact that there's
a lot of messy data out there I've spent
most of my life dealing with large
observational data sets which means
they're very noisy they're very
nonlinear there's missing data and the
default proaches approaches for
statistical methods are often not suited
for that messiness right so if you look
at a textbook example so this is from a
tech I found a textbook example of
regression this is what you get right
points are already lined up for you and
you just got a draw line through it
simple as that
so this is regressing looks like
reported weight on measured weight see
people lie about their weight or
something and you know it can those are
sort of the sorts of examples you get
you feel good coming out of class and
then you go look at real data and
nothing works and makes you sad so real
data looks more like this right so we've
got some of these are baseball examples
actually so there's this swing speed of
a bat against the path angle of the bat
not linear regression they're the this
is a factor over time I'm not sure where
that one came from these are marathon
data marathon timely having just had the
New York Marathon here this is the
Boston Marathon histogram of their of
finishing times another baseball example
where you know it's highly highly
nonlinear okay so real data kind of
looks like that we want methods for
dealing with it so I'm gonna focus on
applications to regression analysis I
assume a lot of you have seen regression
before so just one or two slides on
really what regression is this is kind
of the most general form of a regression
model right it's you're making
predictions about some outcome Y
conditional on a predictor variable or
set of predictor variables X and so G in
the general form can be almost anything
the simplest form is this linear
regression model so if if X is just a
matrix of predictors times some
regression coefficients is this right
it's an intercept plus a bunch of slopes
that's kind of like the example I showed
you before the very simplest one the
univariate linear regression and so
these are kind of the default
assumptions right this is kind of the
default approach to analyzing data just
start with a linear model linear
relationships among the variables and
the other important assumption is
parametric distributions for data all
stall whey is normally distributed right
so the idea here is you make a
prediction based on the predictor
variable and the difference between the
prediction and the observation has this
normal distribution centered on zero and
sometimes that works sometimes it
doesn't
these things generalize but you know if
you take you this is an example we're
gonna see in one of the notebooks this
is spawning salmon and the number of
recruits that they get and you know
linearity holds in some places and not
others but we can generalize linear
models so there's a general form is
generalized linear models where G is
some other function other than identity
and maybe the parametric form of the
distribution of the data is not normal
so common ones here like logistic
regression right so if you've got
failures the zeros and successes the
ones and you try to draw a linear linear
regression you'll get this weird you
know line like this and it's not very
good at predicting anything so now we
transform it we do this logit
transformation right so this is the
inverse logit so it takes this linear
stuff and it puts it on the scale of 0
to 1 and so you're modeling the
probability of a1 instead it's still a
linear model actually even though that's
nonlinear because it's still linear in
the parameters another way of dealing
with non-linearity without leaving
generalized linear models is to do
polynomial regression right where you
even there's even with one predictor
spawning salmon again we could take
number of spawn or squared and add this
polynomial term and make it quadratic
will actually do this in the hands-on
example and you can go crazy the more
the more polynomial terms you add the
closer fit you'll get to the to the data
that is used to fit the model and we
call that overfitting right and so
implicit in this is another step you
have to do which is model selection you
got to pick the right size polynomial
that
neither to to under fit like the linear
example or over fit that's a 15 degree
polynomial on the other side almost
certainly over fit okay whether or not
you do linear models or non linear
models or generalized linear models you
have another choice to make which is we
know what what set of methods what
paradigm do I use to fit these models
and we're going to use Bayesian methods
here and this sort of a this is when we
talk about probabilistic programming
which is one of the newest buzzwords in
in data science it really just refers to
numerical methods computational methods
for doing Bayesian inference and the
reason it's called probabilistic
programming is that Bayesian methods
make inferences and predictions based on
probabilities so everything in Bayes is
a probability distribution and you
manipulate probability distributions to
get answers so almost any model that you
can build in a classical sense
frequentist sense we probably all took
more classical statistics in college if
we took one even if you're not a mystics
major unless you went to school very
recently they were probably always
frequentist methods you were learning
about t-tests and anova z' and
regression you can do all those things
as a Bayesian okay most there isn't
there there are Bayesian versions of
almost everything okay so I'm going to
quickly describe some Bayesian methods
just to make sure everybody has the same
baseline of information this is a part
of Bayes formula these are the
interesting parts of base formula and
what it's what you should notice is that
the thing that we Resta mating over here
is a probability so we're saying the
probability of theta given Y where theta
are the things that are unknown that's
anything in your model that's unknown so
it could be regression parameters if
we're building a regression model like
we're about to do they could be
hypotheses they could be missing data
they could be predictions anything you
don't know you can put into a bay
model and estimate it and then why are
the data so we our inference is what do
we know about theta after having
observed Y and the way that we do that
is we combine what we know about theta
before we observe our data with
information from the data so there's
kind of two pieces here and these things
have names we call this the prior
distribution because it's before we saw
the data this is the likelihood function
Bayesian inference obeys the likelihood
principle that says all information
relevant to the unknown parameters in
your model are contained in the
likelihood and that is combined to get a
posterior distribution okay so but
you'll notice there's no equal sign here
I didn't write an equal sign I wrote
this symbol here which means
proportional to it's equal to up to a
constant and so what it's missing is a
normalizing constant below that
guarantees that this is a probability so
probabilities go in that's a probability
that's not a probability and so we have
to scale it and so the problem is is
that that's the hard part that's the
least interesting part but it's the hard
part and this is the part that's made
Bayesian inference really really
difficult the denominator is just the
numerator integrated over all values of
the unknowns theta so you integrate out
your unknowns so we call it the marginal
likelihood actually the reason it's
difficult is that theta can be pretty
big right there can be lots of
parameters in your model even the
regression model the simple regression
model that we're about to fit has three
parameters and intercept a slope and a
variance or standard deviation of the
error right that's a three dimensional
integration I can't I can't do that I
can do one dimensional sometimes two if
you give me the right easy formula three
forget about it okay most the malls I
build have dozens to hundreds of
variable so you just can't do this in
closed form except in very special cases
any questions about Bayes so far by the
way
I know some of you have done this before
so this is boring review but anything
need clarification okay that's the idea
that's really all I'm going to talk
about in terms of Bayes the whole point
is calculating these posterior
distributions and happily today we have
lots of ways of doing that
in general we even have lots of ways of
doing that just in the context of Python
since this is a PI data conference in
fact there's a Stan tutorial going on
right now and so I'm we use PI and C for
a couple of reasons one is I'm part of
the development team two it's a really
easy way to learn Bayesian inference
because it's a very high level
probabilistic programming language okay
it kind of hides the complexity of the
Bayesian methods it certainly hides the
numerical methods that are used to fit
that so we're not going to concentrate
on what MCMC is and all that stuff we're
going to kind of just assume that for
the moment we're gonna concentrate on
how to specify Gaussian process models
we're going to do it through PI MC this
was started back in 2003 when I was a
postdoc and it's based on piano and
Theano is pour one out for Theon oh it
doesn't really exist anymore it's an
it's a it was a well it's still there
you can still find it but the project is
no longer active it's a framework for
doing deep learning essentially and the
reason what we've done is we kind of
hijacked that deep learning engine to do
probabilistic programming because a it's
a very powerful computational engine and
B it does automatic differentiation for
you does calculates driven s--
automatically and the reason we need
that is that we in prime C we implement
what what I would call next-generation
Bayesian inference methods and those
methods rely on gradient information to
help you get a better idea of what the
posterior distribution looks like so
we're gonna be used methods called
Hamiltonian Monte Carlo and nuts which
are all gradient based and
CMC methods and it's an unfocused
sponsored project and you should all
have it installed on your computer so
let's do the first hands-on and so if
you're if you're doing hands-on I will
do it here too if you're not playing
along so you can watch so one of the
notebooks in the repository is called
spawning salmon I PI and B let me just
open that up
Mia this
and I've opened it up here already I
think I saved them to the repository
unrendered
but I will clear out everything here
we see that at the back what is the
repository it's um it's my last name its
github calm slash my last name /gp
underscore regression and there's a
binder hub hub binder hub tag on there
and you can actually run it in binder if
you don't want to do the whole
installation thing okay
so this is the example that I showed you
already so this is spawning spawning
salmon and what we're gonna do just this
is so the goal here is twofold we're not
going to do GPS quite yet we're gonna
build a regular regression model but
going to do an evasion method a Bayesian
approach using PI MCS so it'll give you
exposure to regression and to PIME C so
building any any any Bayesian model no
matter whether it's nonparametric or not
or parametric it's kind of a three-step
process 1 specify your model to
calculate posterior distribution and 3
check your model so the first step
specifying the model is really here so
we write this down and we turn it into
code so this is the same regression that
we saw earlier on right linear
regression with normal errors and so
what you have to do is figure out what
your priors are and what your likelihood
is remember that unnormalized base
formula we have to specify the left the
right hand side of that formula the
likelihood and the priors and so in this
model we have three unknowns beta naught
beta 1 and Sigma and 1 likelihood which
is the normal distribution which is
where the data goes in ok and so what
I'm going to do is specify zero mean
normals with a standard deviation of 50
for the betas and 1/2 normal with a
standard deviation of 50 for the Sigma's
why did I choose those
because I like those numbers they're
just reasonably large numbers they're
not too big they're not too small part
of model checking as you go back and see
whether those are good assumptions the
idea is you go you know how big could it
possibly be in a biological constraints
of salmon spawning for example right and
how small could it be for example so
these go up to positive and minus 150
we're pretty sure they don't go higher
than that for either of those values and
then here's my half normal so it's just
the absolute value of a normal
essentially okay so those are my priors
here's my data and then up I'm C model
looks like this I'll quickly explain
give you the tour here - t3 uses this
notion of a Python context manager
context manager are usually used to what
you know manage network connections and
files and things and it takes care of
all the business of opening and closing
connections a few other things as well
what we use it for is to build our
models so rather than have you know
instantiate a model and say add this
parameter add that parameter add another
parameter which is fine it's just a
little verbose so what happens here is
any time C object that's created inside
this context manager is automatically
automatically added to the model
yikes little hiccup hopefully it's
coming back I didn't touch anything I
swear okay there it is okay so the nice
thing about I think about PIME C is that
what you write down in code looks a lot
like what you write down in the on the
whiteboard or in markdown in this case
right so here are my priors there's a
beta normal mean 0 standard deviation of
50 and then I do shape equals - I could
have beta naught and beta 1 as separate
normals this is just more compact okay
and then my half normal the same and
then I can just straight-up calculate
this deterministic so this Mew is just a
deterministic linear combination of
the data and the parameters and then
here's my likelihood and likelihood to
look a lot like priors don't they it
looks very much the same thing the only
thing that distinguishes it is this
observed argument so these things have
been observed so they're fixed remember
we conditioned on why this is our
conditioning statement it says we've
observed this node so don't change the
value right observe things don't change
they're no longer random so everything
else gets is treated as random and
that's fixed okay that's it that's the
model I already ran it okay all right
and then once we do that we can press
the inference button as one of the time
seers Tom Thomas Vicki likes to say this
is where we hide everything from you so
we can fit this using Markov chain Monte
Carlo just by calling sample okay and
nuts is the algorithm that's using it's
a automatic it's an auto-tuned version
of hamiltonian monte Markov chain Monte
Carlo and so but don't worry about that
I'm gonna sample two chains you should
always do at least two chains for model
checking purposes okay and I ran it for
a thousand iterations tuning it for two
thousand probably didn't even need that
many it's really a Hamiltonian Monte
Carlo is very efficient okay we can look
at the output okay so there's the
estimate of beta naught about sixty
slope of about 0.53 or so and then and
then Sigma okay and then the nice thing
is is that we can now sample so
everything everything this this
represents the posterior uncertainty in
those parameters we if we collected you
know if we had millions of observations
of spawning salmon these would
essentially be point probabilities with
no uncertainty around them so as we get
more information these things kind of
collapse to a point so it's not the
distribution it's not that we're saying
these things are random and they can be
40 on some days and 80s on another it's
a particular value we just don't know
what it is so we're using probability
here to express our uncertainty okay and
then we can sample from that means
sample candidate
true regression lines right but this
this is forced to be linear okay so it's
sort of squint at it kind of looks a
little nonlinear because of where the
data is sitting but these are just
straight lines right and then as we said
we can generalize this to a quadratic or
like a polynomial model we'll use a
quadratic so with quadratic we're just
adding another x2 term right we're
squaring the spawners and adding it to
the model so this is exactly the same as
the previous one but with two changes
one we have three regression parameters
here instead of two and here's where we
add it and it's x squared which is the
other term and so now we have a
quadratic model we run it just the same
has a little more trouble with this one
now it's found it so it does a bunch of
tuning so sometimes it could be slow
initially okay now we have one that's
you know somewhat better fit than than
the last one right we might try a cubic
term or something like that or or you
could use a totally different model
structure if you wanted to ok any
questions about PI MC model building or
regression
okay all right we're gonna go back to
the slides for the moment can leave that
open because there we're going to use
this data again
- unreal I go
oh sorry yeah yeah so this is the magic
of Jupiter just like latex so backslash
alpha al al pH a and then you hit tab
and Jupiter magically turns it into the
magic of Unicode so they're just late
tech characters okay all right so that's
regression and Bayes now on to why we
came here which is GPS so what we're
gonna do here is build flexible
non-linear models with gaussian
distributions with normal distributions
and this doesn't seem like a very good
idea right because we've seen what
normal distributions look like they're
symmetric they have very narrow tails
everything's really close to the mean it
doesn't seem particularly flexible for
modeling messy data well it gets better
when you have more than one of them so
the normal generalizes to the
multivariate Gaussian in the
multivariate normal so this is the
bivariate case where we have two
elements all right and so we have rather
than a a mean and a variance we have a
mean vector and a covariance matrix and
the important thing is that the often so
these are just the marginal variances
for each for y1 and y2 but the important
thing are these off diagonal elements
which is the covariance which includes
this correlation term here so it's the
correlation between x y1 and y2 and it
determines you know how much we know
about y1 for example given the value of
y2 the root their quote more closely
related to one another so as as so Rho
goes between zero and one where zero is
completely uncorrelated and one is
completely correlated ok there are two
important properties two gaussians that
make them very handy for building
nonparametric models the first is the
fact that it's really easy to
marginalize what we mean by marginalized
you
is when you have a big multivariate
Gaussian with hundreds of elements and
elements and you only want a few of them
it's really easy to get rid of the ones
you don't want marginalize them out so
let's say x and y are not just two
values let's say it's a whole array of
values say we only want half of them we
just want to get rid of Y so we have to
do this right we have to integrate out Y
which seems we just I just finished
saying how hard multivariate integration
is right but if it's a normal
distribution it's really easy you just
cover that up and you cover these up and
it and all you do is you pull out that
top quadrant for the covariance function
and that Sigma X is your new covariance
matrix no math to be done whatsoever
similarly it's really easy to condition
and it might be clear why we need to do
conditioning right given the value one
value in our multivariate normal what do
we expect some unobserved value or the
next value to be it's not quite as easy
it's not a matter as much a matter of
you know pulling out individual values
but you can write it down in closed form
there's an analytic solution to it okay
so there's a conditional mean so the
it's the it's the marginal mean plus
some other term and the conditional or
the marginal covariance minus some other
term that we can easily calculate okay
so we can condition and marginalize
really easily the reason we want to do
this is that we're going to generalize
the multivariate normal to not just
contain many many elements but contain
infinite elements okay so what we're
going to have is a thing that we call a
Gaussian process that rather than having
a mean and a covariance matrix has a
mean function and covariance function
right because you can think of functions
as sort of being generalizations of
arrays right if you had an infinite
number of objects you don't want to
store those and access them like a
dictionary or something you'd want to
create a function that generates the one
you need as you
eat it right because you can't store
infinity on a computer so that's the
idea so this is the textbook definition
of a Gaussian an infinite collection of
random variables any finite subset of
which have a Gaussian distribution so
it's an infinitely large Gaussian and
anytime you take any subset of them you
just have a regular multivariate normal
of whatever that size is you can see
where that marginalization thing comes
in right because you'll never want to
deal with all infinite all infinity of
them you'll just want to deal with the
ones you've observed or the ones you're
trying to predict never all of them at
once okay
so it's kind of a yet again
statisticians have named things poorly
and so it's it's not nonparametric
implies you know no parameters it's
actually we have an infinite number of
parameters but a better way of thinking
of it is that the number of parameters
the effective number of parameters
scales with your data
it means bigger models more data allows
you to build a bigger model smaller data
allows you to build a smaller model
that's usually a good thing you don't
want to build small models with large
data it's it's kind of dumb
similarly you don't want a big build a
model that's too big with lots and lots
of data it's the bias-variance tradeoff
sort of right okay so this is it a
couple things to notice is that what
we're doing here is we're modeling
functions now right these are functions
so every realization of a Gaussian
process is not a set of numbers it's an
entire function so we're going to model
this underlying function of spawning
salmon or marathon finishing times or
age effects of some disease we're going
to model the function directly not its
parameters and in particular the
covariance function the realization of a
covariance function is a covariance
matrix so you pass the function a
certain number of values and it returns
the covariance matrix corresponding to
those values
so the the most important thing about
creating Gaussian processes is figuring
out what your covariance functions going
to be and depending on the one you
choose you can fit different types of
functions so for example if you pick a
Gaussian process prior that has a
quadratic it's called an X there's lots
of names for this one sometimes it's
just called the Gaussian covariance
function which is kind of misleading
exponential quadratic is what we call it
in pi of Z it's got one main parameter
which is a length scale which determines
kind of how how far you have to go away
between two points to make them more or
less independent and you just kind of
get these you know sort of smooth ish
lines so this is a prior right no data
this is sampling from a prior with a
Gaussian process with a quadratic x Bob
exponential quadratic covariance
function another popular one is the
maturing ssin it's a little more
flexible you can see a little more
jagged so it's also also got a length
scale but it's got this parameter that's
usually fixed to some number like one
half three halfs five halfs and it
determines kind of how rough it is so if
you have something that changes
potentially very quickly over small
scales this can be a good one
you can use it to model things that are
periodic cosine covariance function okay
there's a whole suite of them if you go
into any of the packages that do GPS
most of them will come with a library of
covariance functions and these
covariance functions are just they're
basically just kernels if you're
familiar with kernel models there are
some function of distance because that's
the whole game here I remember the
covariance between x and y and that
first bivariate normal that's kind of
where the power is here it's kind of
what what does this point tell me about
that point then there's the mean
function we don't pay a lot of attention
to the to the mean function it's a
function that generates mean vectors and
will actually usually just set this to
something simple like zero or a constant
linear function maybe in the for the
growth term in that salmon spawning
example the reason is is that it turns
out that the posterior Gaussian process
doesn't involve what the mean which
seems a little weird but it's true what
it is useful for is as sort of as prior
information you can consider the mean
function as a prior guess at what that
function might be because wherever
there's no data whenever there's no data
in a Bayesian model it what does it do
it shrinks towards the mean that's
because that's the only information
you've got if there's no date no
information your new data and
everything's based on what your prior
assumptions are and so for something
like a growth curve you could assume
that it's just okay in the absence of
information we just Sam and just keep
growing till infinity okay all right so
what I'm going to do is draw from a
prior Gaussian process so these are
priors over functions another definition
of Gaussian process is a distribution
over functions so rather than a
distribution over values it's a
distribution over functions so every
realization is not a number and
sometimes this presentation is a little
confusing because of this although I'm
going to generate I'm going to generate
a kind of point by point but I'm gonna
generate functions from this prior and
you can do it point by point which is
how I'm gonna do it you don't have to so
here's the prior it's got a zero mean
and a quadratic exponential exponential
quadratic covariance function with
length scale one and so it kind of looks
like this and that's just kind of a
standard deviation two standard
deviation band okay and what I'm gonna
do is just pick a arbitrary point I
think I'm gonna pick one or something
like that and I'm just going to draw a
value and this will be unconditional
because there's no points existing right
now and so the the code is down here so
we go into numpy draw a random normal
with the scale whatever our scale is at
point one and we get some number right
it'll be obviously different every time
so that in this example sorry this is
what happens right and so we're gonna
assume for the moment there's well this
is a prior so there's no observation
noise that's our point
that's one
this drawn function the next point I
draw has to be conditional on this point
so I'm going to draw from a conditional
distribution now remember conditioning
is easy for nor it for normals so
there's a conditional function here I've
implemented it it's just that
conditional function that I drew before
it's not no magic and I pick arbitrarily
point negative 0.7 draw a conditional
normal and it's right there okay and so
you can see we're kind of you know
building a link sausage here right and
and you can see we're sort of carving
away we're gonna get you can see already
what this lines kind of gonna look like
based on what our covariance function is
right it'll sort of look like that red
line more or less and in principle we
could take all you know we can take
infinity in two points if we had the
time we don't need to to characterize it
but that's just one random draw I did it
here's four more from the same function
okay so these are just draws from that
prior so it's a prior on whatever we're
trying to model okay we convert that
into a posterior once we've seen some
data and we need software usually to do
that so questions about the prior and
the GP prior I'd be surprised if there
weren't any questions
it's not even uniform it's a normal with
a mean of the normal infinite normal
mean of 0 with this covariance function
that describes a bunch of covariance
matrices between any number of points
I'd choose them arbitrarily I just
packed I would so if I were to draw if I
were to if I wanted to generate a bunch
of them I'd do numpy linspace 0 100 and
just draw a line I would do it all at
once I wouldn't do a point I did it
point by point for kind of illustrations
sake but each time you point
the possibilities of the point next to
it but not so much the points far away
correct unless I had a really big length
scale the length scale was really big it
means that things are highly correlated
even far out and so you'd get these big
you know curvy things that are like this
as opposed to you know that kind of you
still get the same you know eventually
you want to get a line right something
that represents a line so you wouldn't
pick random there would be no reason to
pick randomly we're doing conditional
we're just doing conditioning you might
be modeling Grint Brownian motion we
don't know this is just a prior you
wouldn't use a exponential quadratic to
model Brownian motion that matern would
be closer right because it was very
jagged the functions I was drawing we're
not very jagged yeah any other questions
yes
between thinking about it just as like
every point in your expertise function
yep
yeah no because again you can
marginalize condition whatever way you
want the infinite stuff is out every any
point you want access is always there
for you to calculate but you can't you
know in practice all you're interested
in is the one ones where you've observed
data the ones that you're trying to
impute maybe or or extrapolate to so you
they're always a bit because you've got
a function you can always ask for a
point you just don't hold them in memory
all the time yeah okay
so there's lots of ways of getting of
doing GPS really easily in Python and
they range from high level to low-level
interfaces tensorflow probability just
added them and they're very low level if
you like to write tensorflow have at it
pie stan is there very low level - you
kind of have to roll your own pie MC and
scikit-learn or very high level right
you just say Gaussian profile we'll see
how we do it in Plan C but scikit-learn
it's just a class like you know random
forests or something the other one is G
PI GP float G PI torch they're sort of
in the middle you have to kind of write
classes which some people like to do and
others do not so you have wide wide
range of approaches alright so let's go
back to our salmon recruitment now how
would we do a GP for the salmon model
that we just fit linear models - so you
know again looks like that and the cool
thing is we don't have to say that it's
you know polynomial or exponential or
log linear or whatever all we have to do
is is do Bayesian stuff so the way it
works just like any other Bayesian model
you specify your model or specify your
probabilities calculate posteriors do
model checking so we have to specify
prior and a likelihood and in this case
a prior is gonna be a GP that's the
thing we were just manipulating our data
is gonna be Gaussian you can argue
whether or not this data is Gaussian it
it works as Gaussian they're just count
their numbers of spawning offspring
maybe something else is better but we're
gonna treat them as Gaussian for now and
the nice thing is is that a Gaussian
process prior plus a Gaussian likelihood
gives you a Gaussian process posterior
in closed form it's a relationship known
as conjugate and there's a whole bunch
of examples of conjugant models in Bayes
and this is one of them so makes it
gives us another closed forms way of
doing this so so in Python what we've
got to do now in PI MC we've got a just
as before specify priors for our
unknowns except this time our unknowns
are the hyper parameters for the
covariance functions so this we're going
to use our squared exponential one the
same one I was using before this is that
length scale I told you about and then
if we've added another one here which is
a like an amplitude it's a signal
variance so length scale kind of
determines how things vary along the x
axis it sort of compresses it this way
compresses and expands this way this one
since it's just a value that you're
multiplying it by so it's going to
expand on the y axis here so we got two
unknowns here we don't have to have that
by the way it just makes it more
flexible so we've just anytime you add a
parameter you're making things more
flexible so I'm gonna use half Koshi
distributions what's the half Koshi
distribution a Cosi distribution is kind
of like a normal distribution with
really really really really long fat
tails it allows the possibility for
really extreme values right remember
normal has that that attribute where you
know 67% of the values are between two
standard deviations or within one
standard deviation of the mean and
around 95 of them are within two
standard deviations of the mean not the
case with a Koshi it's got it's got
really peaked and then it's got really
broad tails and then this is just gonna
be the positive half because both of
these because
our scale parameters they always have to
be positive so we want negative values
so it's a good thing to use as priors
because it says we're pretty confident
that you know the value is going to be
relatively close to zero but they could
be leaves open the possibility for
really extreme value so you're not
binding yourself into a corner okay and
so here's our exponential quadratic
there is row there's a de and then
here's my mean function remember I said
we could set the mean to anything and
here's where I'm putting that linear
function and I'm just going to take the
rise over the run of the data which is
kind of cheating for baize right because
I'm using the data to specify the prior
but that it really won't matter you
could easily have just put 0 there and
then what we're going to do is take a
marginal Gaussian process so this is
marginal because it's this closed form
thing if we've got Gaussian data with a
Gaussian process we get Gaussian and so
all we have to do is optimize that
marginal likelihood that that
denominator which we now have in closed
form here okay there's the marginal
likelihood in fact so here's the just
like if we are building a model this is
the noise so this is the observation
noise we're dealing with data now not
everything is gonna be described by the
underlying process so here's the
marginal likelihood this is the
equivalent of the regular likelihood in
a Bayesian model except this is the
marginal likelihood and we pass it X the
number of points because we don't want
to deal with infinite points we just
were interested in X points this is the
grid of values over which we have
observations and then here's here are
the outcomes and there's my notes okay
and that all I'm going to do here is
optimize so the cool thing is you don't
have to do crazy MCMC stuff although you
can we can just optimize so find map is
stands for find maximum a-posteriori
which is the post the maximum of the
posterior distribution so it's just
going to he'll climb to the maximum
value
if we're interested in the uncertainty
of our hyper parameters then you can do
MCMC we'll have an example where we can
do that but you don't have to so
officially it's not you know like fully
Bayesian okay and then how do we make
predictions how do we you know once we
have the values where we have observed
data how do we go back and get other
values like if we wanted to draw the
full line this is no different than in
any other Bayesian setup we use the
posterior predictive distribution so the
posterior predictive distribution is how
we make predictions with a Bayesian
model and it involves two components the
posterior this is the posterior we're
just we've just been estimating and that
that is our you know epistemic
uncertainty so it's the our unknowns and
then there's alia torque uncertainty so
things like noise and the observation
noise right so you've got to incorporate
the stochasticity of our data generating
process this is essentially our
likelihood here as well as there are
uncertainty in the parameters okay and
the good news is don't be afraid of the
integration sign we get this for free as
well from sampling from our model okay
so all we do is we pass it new points
that we're interested in and it'll give
us predicted values after having fit our
model okay just like if you're using
scikit-learn you fit your you fit your
boosted tree model and then you pass it
predict and it generates brick did
values this is the same thing here
so in pi MC it looks like this so we we
create this conditional remember we're
doing now conditional prediction over
some range of spawners so let's say I
want to know everything from 0 to 500 so
that's why I was talking about with you
so you linear space and we're just going
to predict from 0 to 500 and then oops
this is out of date we rename sample PPC
to sample posterior predictive because
it's more descriptive and then we pass
it the model the fitted model the
Verrier variables that we're interested
in which is this one I'm
going to draw three little samples which
will see if we go back to our notebook
which we'll do now any questions about
specifying the model we're just about to
do it by hand here so
here it is right
all right so here's the GP this is just
exactly what I had written on the slides
and you know feel free you know this is
your hands on time you can change some
of this stuff if you want to if you want
to play with different length scales
different priors feel free and oh I
didn't do okay all right so here I am
gonna do MC MC I thought I had done
maximization we can do both actually so
the difference here is so if I do find
map I'm just gonna get single values for
each of these just the estimated maximum
values now I get distributions of values
okay whereas fine map would have given
me you know that value of that value and
probably something up close to zero for
here and then and then here's the
conditional piece so now I'm going to
draw just draw free candidate lines okay
all right and so that you know each of
these could potentially be the true
underlying process and and you can see
it's kind of interesting because you
know the whole idea the whole conundrum
with nonlinear models is you know do you
believe that there's this weird dip you
know around 350 spawners probably not
know if you know anything about the
biology there's no reason why that
should happen but the data is the data
there it is and so some of the lines
think it is and some of the lines think
it doesn't and so you can generate a
whole bunch of these so I can go back in
and generate a hundred and you can see
here that you know basically every line
is kind of like a vote for the true
posterior right most of them are kind of
passing it by but they're still
uncertainty they're right they're still
uncertainty whereas if we had collected
millions of points there'd be it would
be a line basically through the data
okay
these are drawers from the posterior
without any observation noise so this
these are what we think the true line is
if we can also draw ones with prediction
noise so including the noisy bit so this
would be if we want to predict new
observations here we're predicting the
underlying line which is subject
stochasticity and now you can see now
you should see most of the points within
kind of the band that you get okay so if
you wanted to generate new predicted
observations this is what you would use
if you were interested in the latent
process so to speak you would leave the
noise out
I'll skip this exercise leave it for you
so what happens if we you know want to
project outwards what happens at six
hundred eight hundred and Beyond right
well if we know something about biology
you start hitting you know starting to
curve because there's density dependence
right it starts to to many salmon it
gets crowded and they can't produce as
well the but just like anything else you
have to be careful about extrapolation
with Gaussian processes because once you
get far enough away from the data what
happens what does it start to look like
if you have no data if there's no data
in a Bayesian model what does it rely on
prior so go best with prior remember the
prior was was just a straight line like
this so it'll say salmon all the way up
right so the only only you only want to
trust upon a extrapolation depending on
how big your length scale is so if your
length scale is pretty long you might be
able to trust a bit of an extrapolation
but other than that there's a example in
on the PI MC documents of the co2 data
right that's going up and up and up and
when you extrapolate it on it it goes
down again and say oh we're saved we're
gonna it's all going to go down in a few
years but it's just because we had a
zero mean prior mean and so it goes back
to the mean one year no data left so you
have to be very careful about
extrapolate how we're doing on time half
an hour cool pretty good
questions
yes you may be interested in two
different things one is what do I think
the underlying reproductive reproduction
curve looks like your expense or your
expected value right with there but
there's noise you know like these values
down here are probably due to noise not
due to a process right so if you don't
include the noise all you're getting is
the estimated posterior of that
underlying function that you're trying
to estimate if you add noise you're
including how how far away from that
expected value could observations be
because we've also estimated Sigma which
is our normal you know I'm white noise
process essentially right and so that is
better for predicting observed values
where could or not how high so in other
words if we observed value down here
then something's wrong something's wrong
with our model then we've underestimated
the noise or what we've estimated the
wrong model but all of these MA all
these points are comfortably well not
necessarily comfortably but well inside
there's always a point that goes below
it so it's contained inside of this sort
of envelope of uncertainty so this
includes stochastic uncertainty as well
as parametric uncertainty so are we
predict are we interested in estimating
the function or estimating interested in
estimate predicting new values this is
for predicting new values
okay
all right yeah so we saw this
okay this is uh-oh this one's on the log
scale sometimes nicer to look at on the
log scale that's the same thing with the
stochastic noise on there again okay all
right on to the next example
so mmm you could accuse me of being all
textbook on you yeah give you an example
that's normal prior normal data
good all right sorry about that
all right so what if I what
a shot
this is weed they actually these are our
own that we brought for the event
because the the building didn't have a
visa for these rooms so all right this
that looks a green light at least yeah
that rat hearing me okay all right turn
it off and on again it works every time
doesn't it
okay what I say oh yeah
counts of disasters so every year mining
collapses and things and so these are
count data typically you don't model
count data with normal distributions one
because counts are discrete rather than
continuous right and also there's
usually a mean variance relationship as
the mean goes up the variance usually
goes up so and what I've just described
our characteristics of different
distribution called the Poisson
distribution so you'll often see Poisson
distributions used to describe count
data so our likelihood is going to be
different now
so we're going to assume that our data
our Poisson distributed and our prior is
still Gaussian so Gaussian plus plus on
we can't we can't do our nice marginal
GP now we have some sort of transformed
Gaussian process so it's a we've given
ourselves a little bit bigger of a
challenge so for that we have to do we
have to use a slightly different kind of
Gaussian process and we call this a
latent GP latent means there is a
Gaussian thing in there somewhere but
we're gonna transform it so that it's
the mean of a Poisson because the mean
of the poison has to be positive because
it's modeling counts and you can't have
negative counts so everything looks very
similar it looks the same up till here
actually right except they used
exponential inexplicably rather than
half Koshi it probably doesn't matter
you as an exercise you could go in and
swap them out and see that it won't
matter other than that it's the same
except now rather than marginal it says
latent
okay and Layton just says there's that
we're gonna there's another step there's
gonna be a different posterior
distribution you can't just use the
closed form way from before so the
transformation we have to make is take
this prior which is the GP prior which
is Gaussian that can have negative
values and how do you make something
negative positive take the exponential
of it right so inverse log transform so
exponential of whatever F is it'll
guarantee that all your values are going
to be positive so we've done away with
that boundary in pi MC those sorts of
transformations will be rap in a
deterministic nodes this is just an
arbitrary deterministic transformation
and then we as a Poisson likelihood
rather than a normal here so our
likelihood is poised on now where the
expected value is lambda and then here
are disasters here the year is here and
it expects a 2d array so we have to add
a empty dimension all right so that's
the big change here is rather than
marginal we have a latent with prior
okay
and so be the same as before call MCMC
on it and let's give it a try
okay it is mining disasters and small
data set so it's just right here in one
of the cells oops let me restart the
kernel I must have been messing around
with this before
alright there's the data so this parts
the same except for the latent part so
there's our GP latent or prior
Poussin and pisces got most of the
important numpy functions that you'd
want but they're buried inside of p.m.
math and that's because they're actually
piano functions so you want them to be
theano functions whenever you can and
then we'll sample
right
don't think I need this actually
by default pi FC will use half as many
cores as your machine has so on this so
we'll use for so I'm just telling it to
use to just so no one he's that much
although as many as you can is best for
model checking
nothing like watching MCMC run
yeah the next example we're not even
gonna do hands on because it takes a
long time yourself
I need to get warnings divergences so I
told you about gradient-based MCMC and
so tries to follow the gradient of the
posterior sometimes it diverges and goes
off into a weird place and it reports
how many divergences you get if they're
just a couple it's usually okay there
are Diagnostics in the RV's package
which is being used to plot these things
that you can these are probably okay
I've done this model enough to know but
okay and so now so what we did in the
example that that we use for pi MC in
general is what we use is this for as a
change point model where we say there's
an early mean some regulatory thing
happened in here to change safety or
something and then there's a lower mean
down there and so a very simplified
regression piecewise constant model very
simple model this is saying this allows
for you know arbitrary changes in the
underlying risk if you like for a
disaster and you can see that it you
know there was sort of a step in here
but it could be non constant who knows
yes that's just overfitting noise or
something is there a way to change the
prior to so we've because we've done
MCMC it's taken that uncertainty into
account right so these are the posterior
so here's the length scale so if the
length scale truly is up around 11 then
it will be smooth and if you know zoomed
in on this you'll see some of those
lines are going to be almost straight
you'll change over a much longer period
of time whereas others don't so that
uncertainty that's the nice thing about
this is that there's no over there no
overfitting here it's just that that
it's because a realization is a function
so there's you can't add or subtract
parameters from an infinitely parametric
model so not that you can't over fit a
GP but it's it's pretty hard
yeah because the marginal you can only
use the marginal when it's that
conjugate normal normal because it makes
the the posterior closed form and so all
you have to do so that that big integral
that's under at the bottom of base
formula is closed form and you can
actually just maximize that to get your
get your hyper parameter values so it's
a lot easier this there's no conjugacy
involved and so you've got a you've got
to build that what so what it does is it
builds a latent GP and then transforms
the normal with a and uses that place on
likelihood and so it's just a harder so
you can't you can't you can't specify it
in closed form basically that's so a
tape you can the model took a little bit
longer it's a little bit more costly
computationally but structurally they're
they're different the thing that's being
optimized is different in a marginal
model versus Lane model yes
goshen prior as well even first that
dispersion
a Gaussian process prior the the
Gaussian process prior is on the log of
the so we're modeling if you go back up
to the model we're modeling the the log
rate except essentially so we're
modeling the Poisson rate that's a rate
of accidents and the Gaussian process
describes the log rate of that so if you
take that positive value you take the
logarithm of it you'll get something
that's on the real line and you can you
say that that's normally distributed so
that's it's going to be Gaussian but
it's the latent thing that's go sein not
the observed thing everybody else
really do something like ended like over
discourse what's on it one thing yep
yeah so hold on let me well I'm talking
I'll change the priors and see what
difference it makes
yeah so there is a there is still there
are still choices to be made about the
likelihood and the priors like I'm just
testing now what he's what's your name
sorry Alan what Alan was suggesting is
that the Poisson distribution may still
not be suitable for counts because
sometimes counts are over dispersed
which means so the Poisson has only got
one variable lambda and it describes the
mean and the variance well it's not all
sometimes you get situations where the
mean of the variants aren't the same and
so a negative binomial distribution is a
generalization of that that allows for
over dispersion so that's a slightly
more complicated model so you could try
that and do model selection to see which
one's the best
I usually try I usually start with the
simpler model check the goodness of fit
and if the fit is okay I just leave it
alone if the fit is poor then I'll make
it a more complicated model
and it's running even slower with the
half Koshi
and all I'm gonna do is do a another
plot of the posteriors salute a and see
if there are any different
fewer divergences
so it looks like the link scale is a
little bit more sensitive which makes
sense the Koshi prior has a little bit
longer of a tail let's see what kind of
a difference that makes to this
so there see this one is a little
flatter so it looks like it's a little
smoother okay and you can do
goodness-of-fit checks to see which of
these are is preferred but it's not
overly sensitive okay back to the pardon
me the red lines are drawers their
posterior drawers yeah I haven't done
any mean it's the posterior draw of the
latent process the estimate of lambda
over time okay
all right and so we have yeah plus your
hyper parameter estimates which we just
saw okay
another non normal model that I'll
quickly go through this one won't have a
hands-on component so this is from I
used GPS in in practice for this before
I was in baseball it was about
statistics professor at Vanderbilt and
we're studying infectious disease
dynamics and one of the things about
measles is that people show up with
symptoms of measles but they sometimes
don't have measles they'll have rubella
or something else and so there's a bias
having to do with detection bias
sometimes you overestimate or
underestimate the numbers of cases here
we're talking mostly about over
estimation so this is confirmation bias
so you test somebody out in the field
you you give a quick response based on
the test that you do there but then
you've lab confirm it to make sure and
some of the lab confirmations come out
negative and so to properly model it you
want to correct for that and so this is
exactly the same as the other one
latent GP exponential priors and now I'm
just using a binomial right because this
one is out of how many potential cases
how many were actual measles cases all
right so now I'm estimating the
confirmation bias and measles and it
looks like this age this is always
there's the most frequent application
for me for GPS is and these sort of age
specific things because age is almost
notoriously nonlinear for a lot of
things so you can see it goes down for
kids and then goes back up for some
adults and then and then the cool thing
is is that you know you get you get some
uncertainty out here for elderly folks
because there are fewer much fewer cases
that the size of the points represents
the number in that age category so tiny
points here are bigger more cases in
here right so very useful and often I do
this this you can roll this into another
model this could just be a component of
a lark this is a component of a larger
model
modeling the dynamics of measles this is
just a correction for the bias that is
age specific and it's important to take
that into account and here again you
don't you know how would you model that
parametrically it would be difficult you
some you'd have to do some polynomial
thing okay all right but 15 minutes left
so so I've shown you the good news the
things that Gaussian processes can do
now the bad news and we're in the age of
big data Gaussian processes are not
typically good for large data sets and
the reason is you have to look at the
posterior distribution of the posterior
Gaussian process so this is the
posterior of the covariance function so
k star means posterior covariance
function and it has a nice closed form
like we saw before this is the marginal
piece but if you look closely you take
the covariance function evaluated at X
which is the data and you do something
to it and then you invert it so you're
inverting a X by X matrix so if you've
got a thousand data points it's in a
thousand by thousand matrix inversion
and it quickly is it's very hard to do
it's cubic in compute time and quadratic
in memory and so it really large models
take a long long time and often croak so
what we do is we approximate instead so
what we can do is rather than have a
full prior based on all the observed
data we get sort of representative
points of the data and use them as what
they call inducing points and we have a
sparse approximation to our prior so we
have these things called pseudo inputs
that are of size M which we presume to
be much smaller than n like you'd pick
for that measles example you might put
five or something like that so it
reduces the number of matrix eigen
vectors that are used to fit the data
essentially and so it reduce
the expressiveness of the GP but it all
sometimes doesn't matter so the example
I'm going to use is that Boston Marathon
data set that I briefly flashed up at
the beginning so 2015 over 26,000
finishers it's crazy that many people
are running marathons these days these
are the really fast ones too you have to
qualify for Boston so you'd have so to
fit a regular GP to this data you'd have
to invert a 26,000 by 26,000 matrix
which good luck with that right so
that's what the data looks like if we
want to do is get we're after is the
expected finishing time over the all of
the age groups and so what we do is just
add one additional piece here which is a
set of inducing points we'll call them X
U and you can specify them yourself for
data this dense it doesn't matter very
much you can probably just say 1 2 3 4 5
etc but PMC has a nice utility function
that picks them using k-means so it just
does clustering along the line and
they're not useful clusters in the sense
of clustering things but it's you know
it'll find good places to situate points
and it's more important when things are
actually clumped in different places
other than that it's all the same right
except now we're using marginal sparse
unfortunately this does not work at
least in pi MC 3 in the latent case so
if you've got large data that is not
Gaussian you're kinda out of luck you
got a roll you can't not that you can't
do it we just don't have these high
level classes to take care of it so I'm
gonna pick 20 inducing ok it says 20 but
I actually took 10 and and then
everything else is the same marginal
likelihood this looks exactly the same
except we're also passing Xu here and it
will expect that any time the GP itself
is marginal sparse it'll say where are
your inducing points and there are a lot
of different ways of doing these
inducing points the defaults think fit C
is the default I just wrote it out to be
explicit
it stands for fully independent
conditional they're all just different
methods for reducing that eigenvector
size and different methods work better
in different situations it's always best
to fit a couple of them and see which
ones turn out better and tada
looks like that and this doesn't run in
too long all the time but I don't have a
hands on for this because our last
example which is what we'll go into now
is also going to be sparse so we'll
we'll get a chance to do it by hand as
well okay
all right the last generalization will
do and this is really useful bit I use
this a lot is doing multi-dimensional
Gaussian processes I don't mean on the
input side obviously it's infinitely
dimensional but the output so up till
now we've been modeling univariate time
series mostly or aged series sometimes
we want to do things like spatial stuff
and I use these a lot in the baseball
applications but the example I'll give
you is from a textbook this is a GL from
a geology textbook applied geostatistics
from back in the late 80s these are just
samples from various locations on a
landscape and they're like three
substances and the textbook it doesn't
even tell what the substances are and
they're measurements of each so it's
just V U and T and XY location so our
inputs are going to be X Y and we're
going to model one of the substances
here and the data kind of looks like
this so it looks like what they did is
they went in and had a grid and then
wherever they found you know got a some
threshold value they went in and sampled
more all right so the dis sort of search
strategy so around here so here we're
you know there could be pockets in here
where there's yellow but they didn't
find any so it's sparse relatively
sparse data spatial data two-dimensional
and so what we're gonna do is come up
with the under you know there should be
a true underlying distribution of
substance u that we're trying to
estimate here and it's remarkably easy
to do that this looks very similar to
what we're doing before I'm using a
slightly different covariance function
i'm using the matern remember it's the
jaggedy one i figured you know with
something like this there could be rough
net a little bit of roughness in the
underlying function but the important
thing is you may have noticed before and
chose to ignore that there's always a
one beside the as the first argument in
the covariance matrix
the covariance function and that
specifies the dimension and so so if you
want to make it two-dimensional you just
put it to there and the only the only
constraint on that is that it now
expects two-dimensional inputs so kind
of like declaring a layer in tensor flow
and you've got to have input dimensions
that's the input dimension everything
else is the same there's our marginal
sparse again our inducing points which
come from k-means and then i'm not going
to do MCMC this will take a little while
so yeah that and that and and then after
I'm done right then I want to evaluate
it on a full grid so I go in and I take
a 30 by 30 grid regular grid and I'll
create a heat map at the end of it so I
just passed that big gret Z Z in there
okay so let's do the last example
multi-dimensional GP the marathon one is
in here by the way I think if it's not
I'll make sure it's uploaded after I'm
done clear all outputs
okay it looks like we're modeling
viii we're modeling substance v okay and
then here I didn't actually show you
find Matt before but there is and it's
just doing optimization now because this
is a marginal fast so now we won't have
distributions for the unknown parameters
they'll just have maximum point values
so you are sacrificing uncertainty in
the hyper parameter values
but we are sampling from the posterior
predictive but again it's going to be
conditional on one value for the hyper
parameters I'll get this and so you can
you know I did 30 by 30 you could do a
hundred 100 and get a nice smooth one
looks better whatever you need all right
almost at the end here so I will wrap it
up
and this is the same as creaking if
you've done geostatistics before if
you're done creaking you've already done
Gaussian processes because they're the
same thing
all right there's plenty more where this
can't this is just to whet your appetite
give you the basics as I said before you
can do classification with GPS that's
when you do that use a latent right and
that would be like up Bernoulli or a
binomial thing where you're classifying
something as 1 or 0 the kernels the the
covariance functions are additive and
multiplicative so if you have something
that is say periodic but also you know
like the co2 levels in the atmosphere
you can combine a linear kernel with a
cosine kernel and model components of
things there's a really good example in
gell-mann's textbook Bayesian data
analysis where they model births through
at different days throughout the year
and they use a seasonal component and a
component for holidays and a component
for weekends and all of those things
automatic relevance determination you
can do sort of an automatic model
selection thing if you've got a lot of
variables and you want to you can have a
different what this involves is having a
different length scale for each variable
Bayesian optimization if you're any of
you are machine learners and you want to
one of the best ways to select hyper
parameters is to use Gaussian processes
because there's some underlying surface
that represents how well your deep
learning model performs over different
values of your hyper parameters and what
you want to do is optimize that so you
can model that function directly using
GPS and then you can show that GPS are
related to all these other you can show
that they're related to support vector
machines if you take a neural network
with a hidden layer with an infinite
number of hidden nodes and put normal
priors on the weights
it's a Gaussian process so there there
are links to other things you can make
deep Gaussian processes and so on the
advantages I hope I've made clear it's
flexible you get probabilistic
predictions which are nice interpreter
hyper parameters I think they're I think
they are maybe you don't like scales it
kind of shows how over what scale things
vary over
and it's relatively easy to automate and
the limitation is let us as we saw
scales poorly with large data but if you
look in the GPI torch package they the
creators of that package have come up
with a new method called black box
matrix matrix inducing and it calculates
exact GPS for very very large data sets
and and what it does is it utilizes GPS
and paralyzes the matrix inversion and
it's very fast so I use it I use that a
lot too so so you may want to stray away
from PI and c3 if you've got larger data
sets so other than that I want to thank
the pines III team this is kind of the
current active membership the actual
contributing number is a lot larger than
this in particular bail bill angles bill
angles pretty much single-handedly
developed the GP capabilities of Pi MC 3
over to google Summer of Code summers
and so absolutely amazing stuff and
that's why it was so easy for me to do
this for you today without having to dig
too deeply into the internals of time C
and with that I'll wrap it up and I got
a minute or two for questions
three minutes in fact and then I'm going
to the airport so thank you very much
and I'm happy to take questions if there
are any
yes yeah so you pick those like ten
points and then you're calculating you
essentially have ten eigenvectors so it
it collapses the information in the data
onto those ten points and so you're in
your inverting a 10 by 10 matrix instead
of a million by million
so the different fitzy will do something
like that each one does a slightly
different way of gonna didn't want to
get into the methodology methodological
details but there's a good paper that
summarize if you just look sparse
approximation GP there's one that
summarizes each of them and how they go
about doing it and some will like
underestimate the noise and and then
some will bias things on the hyper
parameter side so different ones there's
always trade-offs when you do these
shortcuts and and so it depends on which
trade-off you're willing willing to make
but yeah and back here
yep yeah no I never throw out data
points and Bayes makes because you have
that posterior predictive distribution
it makes it really easy to impute them
you can do it automatically without
having to throw out any any data so this
does them automatically right any and
anything you don't observe you can
include as a variable in your Bayesian
model and by the fact that it's of GP if
you have an unobserved X it will compute
that for you
if you just ask for it in the
conditional after you fit the data said
we're I wouldn't do it as if it was way
outside the data like I said with the
extrapolation problem but anything near
the data you should get a really good
imputation and that sometimes how
there's creaking you know the hole
that's really what I was doing with that
spatial surface right as I was
interpolating values using this unknown
function estimate
okay thanks everybody
[Applause]